and frank skinner your son buzz what is
he eight now
he's i yeah and already you are steering
him towards a career in comedy i don't
know if i'm steering him
yes i'm steering him i think he's
definitely gonna be a stand-up comedian
i don't have any question about that
he's the only stand-up comedian
i would not mind being funnier than me
oh that's love
that really is love it's also a lie
he actually does stop like stand up like
the other day i was emptying the
dishwasher
and i said you know you empty your
dishwasher and i don't know if you've
ever done this
yes i have still dirty place oh so
annoying
and i said look at this and he said well
if a dishwasher isn't washing the dishes
it's not a dishwasher
it's just a wet cupboard
that is a great light i've seen you know
club comics that would kill for that
are you tempted to no no i look i gave
him the credit then
as you said but now we um yesterday was
um i got up yesterday morning and uh
he said to me uh there's a there's a
leak
in in the bathroom and i thought oh no
and i went into the bathroom and he
placed a leak
on the toilet i mean the vegetable i
think you took a picture there yeah
there you go
as you can see we live in 1970s moscow
i mean it doesn't scream show business
now i've i've managed to keep my feet on
the ground
really yeah but what a great visual gag
and i you know i
i'm so proud
[Music]